what is traditionalism um I don't know
what you think I would say a modern
mentality is me before the family I
would say traditionalism is the family
before me especially in women and so and
so and so what I actually it's
interesting you said 60 year olds
because you know I've interviewed 600
700 people roughly in the past year and
a half I've done hundreds of shows
interviewing people about relationships
and what I find is the 60 year olds tend
to a lot of those women LED their
daughters a stretch you know there's a
reason we're in this mess right a lot of
those women had the wrong mentality when
it came to marriage and had exactly the
mentality that you're talking about